this whole hand is still numb okay
let us know what naughty places you've
put your sticky fingers in the comments
and cut good show guys
Ryan you were off-key when I speak ah
pitchy yes I just got an audition for a
Shetland car dealership commercial
why are you auditioning for a local car
dealership commercial when you're on
Comedy Central Digital no small parts
just small purple and is wrong hmm its
scripted but it says they encourage
improv okay so I'm a car dealer and I
love slashing prices
okay best friends listen to this we take
high prices and cut them like fish maybe
something more family friendly right
kids don't like fish we got prices like
little baby bunny feeling this isn't
constructive
[Music]
all right this is ridiculous
where's Natasha she's not responding to
my emails she's been off running her
audition all day she's obsessed yeah I
don't usually like think about other
people but I'm worried she's way too
into this role what do you mean oh hello
might you be looking to buy a car at a
low low price I sure hope so because
that Shetland we make prices please out
Natasha I think maybe you've been
improvising a little bit too long all
right so why don't you put the knife
down okay yeah yeah dude you gotta check
out the street fair outside Jordan it's
not the best time Pete these bomb-ass
you think you're so cool mr. dollar son
you know what I do to prices like it way
too deep into character I'm gonna slice
up the belly of this unreasonable price
and let all the coins spill out of his
money I mean she can't slice me my face
is my moneymaker that while you were
poor you are ugly
sick burn dude but it is not the time
wait if Jordan dies we have to do his
work mr. price Lester I know you're mad
we're in a some things in this world
aren't fair like like when you get
charged for things you shouldn't we have
to pay extra for guac or having to pay
for porn a premium or having the tip
come in it's not a thing in Europe okay
but even if you slash this one price
what about the other millions of high
prices out there
I don't know miss price slasher you have
a family she does I do a knife daughter
in two-ship sons think about that me
they need you that was great wish me
luck you've acted good so come on down
to Schieffelin car dealership where we
make prices plead out okay
maybe the next one is closer to the
script I feel like that's compromising
my vision and I won't do that in front
of my children
mama lets you
[Music]
you